susan has 96 minutes to complete a test
at school the test begins at 1 59 pm and
susan has volleyball practice at 4 00 pm
how much time will susan have between
the end of the test and the beginning of
volleyball practice so let's think about
this a little bit so the test begins at
1 59 so it's a very it's a very strange
time to begin a test but let's just go
with that so let me draw a little
timeline here
so let's say that this is two o'clock
so this is two o'clock
p.m
then we're going to have
3 p.m
3 o'clock
p.m
then we're going to have 4 o'clock p.m
four o'clock p.m
which is also when volleyball practice
begins so this is volleyball practice is
going to start then and then go on from
4 p.m and then the test begins at 1 59.
so let me continue the number line so
this is
this right over here is 1 pm
1 o'clock
p.m
so the test is going to begin at 1 59 so
1 minute before 2 pm we know that there
are 60 minutes in an hour so 159
is one minute before 2 pm so i'm not
drawing it completely at scale but this
right over here this right over there is
p.m
so we use one minute we use one minute
to get to 2 p.m
and then let's see we have to get up to
96 minutes so then you get another 60
minutes
to go to 3 p.m so so far we've used a
cumulative 61. so this is one minute
this is how long the test has been going
on since the beginning so one minute by
2 pm
61 minutes by 3 pm if we go all the way
to 4 pm that's going to be another 60
that would be 121 minutes which is
longer than the actual test so we know
that the entire test is 96 minutes so
we're going to get to some point right
over here some point like this that's 96
minutes and what we need to figure out
is is what is left over
what is this distance right over here
or what is this time this difference in
time right over here and so to figure
that out we need to figure out the time
at which 96 minutes have passed since
the beginning of the exam
so at three o'clock 61 minutes have
passed and so if we if we say well how
many more minutes have to go on for the
end of the test it's going to be 96
minus 61.
so this the amount of time that elapses
past three minutes is 96 minus 61 which
is 35 minutes so this right over here
this right over here is going to be
is going to be 3
35. and so now our question is how much
time is there between 3 35
and 4 p.m
well once again 60 minutes in an hour
4 p.m is essentially the 60th minute
so if we take 60 minus 35
60 minus 35 we get 2
25. so she is 25 she has a total of 25
minutes remaining after the test before
she gets has to get to volleyball
practice just as a review one minute
between 1 59 and 2 then another 60. that
guess this is 61 total minutes then
another 35 minutes gets us to 96 minutes
have
passed and that also gets us to 3 35
which means we have 25 minutes until 4.